les portes du gymnase la donne et
stevenson sont restés clos ce matin et
un silence pesant émanait de la place
dans celui de stéphane larouche qui a
entraîné plusieurs champions du monde
les mines étaient basses on est
extrêmement déçu et triste lorsque ces
choses là se produit désormais monstre
mais un peu en question également mais
si on considère le nombre de combats qui
se déroulent dans le monde à chaque soir
à chaque fin de semaine
versus le nombre d'accidents vous allez
me dire un accident c'est un trop mais
je pense que le sport est quand même le
plus sécuritaire au moment où on se
parle prend capable de lui conférer à
ces républiques
[Applaudissements]
éric lucas a été champion du monde de
boxe des super-moyens en 2001 il a pris
sa retraite il ya presque dix ans et
aujourd'hui ils s'interrogent depuis
retiré j'ai lu j'ai engagé coûte ce qui
se dit là dessus et c'est ce que des
fois je me dis si j'avais su tout cela
avance que j'aurais boxer ouais c'est
vrai que la façon la plus expéditive de
rapportant combat s'est passé le ko mais
le jeune nick henson de nice est le
champion canadien des poids moyens il
reconnaît volontiers que c'est un sport
dangereux et qui se pose des questions
quand il voit son modèle
adonis stevenson alors pourquoi monter
dans un bus la passion c'est la passion
la boxe une passion je dis moi aussi je
veux dire aussi des fois je pense qu'en
seconde d'orange marque plaisir à jean
piaget européenne jean ping pong ou
bénintendi c'est surtout ça soit arrivé
mais c'est la passion je pensais c'est
lui la discipline que ça porte ses
sujets d'échec c'est mon mental quand on
monte je n'étais pas capable de suivre
six kilos à chaque fois qu'un drame
survient dans un ring le débat sur la
nécessité de ce sport remonte
irrémédiablement à la surface en
attendant qu'il soit réglé
un homme se bat en ce moment pour sa vie
robert frosi radio canada montréal